[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا انها الساعه 60 برنامج
هنا اخباريا خاص ومتنوع و بايقاع سريعا
ومختلف جدا نحلل الاحداث بابعادها وبعمق
وبين العاجل والمهم نضع امامكم الاهم
والصوره الكامله البدايه من العناوين
ورقه الشتائيه
تلعبها انسحبت من خرسون اللي تركز الجهد
على اماكن اخرى الشرق
التظاهرات في ايران تظهر ارتباكا وانقساما
داخليا اعتراف مسؤولين في الخفاء وتحذيرا
من الانتفاضه فقراء
مستمر من ايران واخر من تركيا هل يرجع
السوداني جاره اتت به واخرى تهدده
جوله الامير محمد بن سلمان الاسيويه
خيارات السعوديه متعدده والمستقبل هو
الهدف
[موسيقى]
للحرب منطقها الخاص لا يخضع بالضروره لغرف
العمليات ولضباطها قد تملي الحرب على
القاده قرارات تكون صعبه مثل الانسحاب
الروسي من خرسون وقد تكون متسرعه كتهاني
اوكرانيا لروسيا باسقاط صواريخ على فلندا
كخطه بعد الانسحاب قبل روايه الغرب
والتاكيد على انها صواريخ اوكرانيه هجمت
عن طريق الخطا على الدوله التي تستقبل
اكبر عدد من اللاجئين الاوكرانيين لكن
القصفه الروسيه الشديد على ثياب ومناطق
اوكرانيه قبل الشتاء والثلوجه وان تساقطت
اولا اول قطعه كان رساله من موسكو ما
الانتيكاسات لدينا الامكانيات وليس فقط
الامكانيات بل الخطه ايضا الروس فخخه كل
شيء وهكذا هو الحال في المدينه المنسحبه
روسيا منها اتهام اوكراني الالغم في كل
مكان تحولت خيرسون الى مدينه موت وهكذا
وصفت الجارديان وحتى تعود امنه سيتطلب
الامر سنواتنا طويله وطويله جدا
في اخرى شبه جزيره القرم تعمل موسكو على
التحصين عقله اداره الحرب في روسيا وبعد
تسعه اشهر يبدو ان المنطقه بات يرشده
العقليه الروسيه باتت اهداء في اتخاذ
القرارات ومنذ اكتوبر تحديدا بتعيين
الجنرال السرقه
قائدنا جديدا للعمليات العسكريه بينما
زرعت الالغام وتحسن القرم هناك هدف اخر
عين على الشرق معركه قديمه جديده والتركيز
سيكون بالقرب من دنياك القصو حدث بالفعل
بالقرب من باخمود وافديبيكا بحسب فناجيل
تايمز مجموعه روشان
عددت فوائد اما فلا الانسحاب من خرسون نقل
الموارد بعيدا من الجنوب وتعزيز قواتها
على طول خط الجبهه الشرقيه بلغه الارقام
50% من القوات المسحبه من خرسون يمكن
نقلها لجبهات اخرى نسيمه دوباس لكن هل
تصمت اوكرانيا
لا لديها توجهان تحاول بناء مع حلفائها
نظاما دفاعيا جويا متكاملا تريد حمايه
سماءها والاستعداد للشتاء الذي يقترب وهدف
ثاني وهو محاوله نقل القوات الخاصه بها
الى زفوجيا منطقه اخرى كانت روسيا اعلن
الضمها رفقه خرسانه اذا غنيمه حرب ربما
غريبه انسحاب روسيه من مدينه اعلن قبل
اسابيع ضمها ودون قتال خلصونا مع اوكرانيا
مجددا الزمن
حقق لاوكرانيا ما لم تحققه المعارف
الانسحاب الروسيه من خرسون رغم الحديث انه
كان خطه وصفه انصار بوتين انفسهم في
الهزيمه الاستراتيجيه الابراج
قرروا انسحاب القوات الروسيه من خرسون
الاقليم الذي ضمته موسكو مؤخرا الى هيكلها
جاء وفقا لخبراء عسكريين لعده اسباب منها
اولا صعوبه احتفاظ موسكو بهذه المنطقه
بسبب انعزال القوات الى حد كبير على
الخطوط الامداد وعدم امكانيه دعمها ثانيا
لتجنب الاخطاء التكتيكيه التي ارتكبت خلال
الانسحاب غير المنظم منخارف ومنعه وقوع
ضحايا بين القوات واعاده تجمعها وتدريبها
للاحتفاظ بخطوط المواجهه الحاليه القرار
كان صعبا لكنه عقلاني هكذا وصفه بعض
المسؤولين الروس مثل الرئيس الشيشاني
رمضان
لكنه لاقى انتقادا من المتشددين منهم
وعلى وجه الخصوص الفيلسوف القومي الروسي
الكساندر دوجن الذي شبهها تسليما مدينتي
خرسون بتسليم اي مدينه روسيه اخرى
ورغم التقارير عن خطه بوتن لكن الخيارات
امامه لم تكن كثيره الانسحاب ضروره لا
تقبل التاجيل 10,000 جنديا في الضفه
الغربيه من نهر
باتوا شبه محاصرين منذ تدميري
شريان حياتهم الوحيد وبحلول الشتاء تتضاعف
احتياجاتهم من الوقود والمعدات ويحول دون
وصولهم اليها حصول كيف علامه فعاليه بعيده
المدى النهر والجسر والمدفعيه الاوكرانيه
ضد روسيا في خرسون زفت الى اشهر ولم يتم
تعويض الخسائر في الافراد والمعدات في
الوقت المناسب ولم يبقى امام القياده
الجديده الا امرا وحيد التخطيط الانسحاب
المنظم
اوكرانيا تستعد المدينه لي يشبه الامر
بانزال النور
القرار الروسي بالانسحاب من خرسون تراه
اوكرانيا انتصارا لها وتصفه القياده
السياسيه والعسكريه في البلاد بالقرار
الاجباري نتيجه لهجوم المضاد للقوات
المسلحه الاوكرانيه التي اخترقت خطه دفاع
روس في خرسون بسبعه وثلاثين كيلوباترا
واستعاده ما يقاربوا الفن 2381 كم مربعا
منذ بدايه اكتوبر حتى اصبحت القوات
المسلحه الاوكرانيه على تخوم المدينه كما
قامت المدفعيه الاوكرانيه بقطع طرق
الامداد والطرق الاستراتيجيه خلف خطوط
الروس الامر الذي اجبرهم على الانسحاب في
هذا التوقيت حتى لا تقعوا قواته والمعدات
والاليات العسكريه الثقيله فريسه لحصار
الجيش الاوكراني
السؤال هل انسحبت موسكو بلا خطه بديله لا
لديها بدائل تضاف ولما ذكرته سابقا بل
وبمزه التكلفه اقل الجيش الروسي الان بصدد
بناء خطا دفاعيا ثابت الشرقيه النهر الخطه
تهدف الى تجنب الخسائر طيله الشتاء
وامتصاص قوه الهجوم الاوكراني وتجميد
الحرب سيسمح ايضا بتحضير الجيش للمرحله
القادمه وبما ان الحرب في اوكرانيا هجينه
وتلعبوا على مستويات مختلفه مواطن اخر
حاول بوتان
وهو افتتاح المجال امام الحرب الاقتصاديه
والهدف استهدافه ذخيره دائما وربما الرغبه
في مواصله تقديم التضحيات سحاب وروسيا من
مدينه خرسان عسكريه يعني الكثير خطط تطبيق
مدينه ميكو لايف والتقدم نحو اوديسا بما
يسمح بعزل اوكرانيا عن البحر الاسود سقطت
في الماء على الاقل تاجلت حتى الربيع
موسكو كانت تعمل ابي بنائي ممر بريا الى
منطقه ترانس نسريه الانفصاليه في مولدوفا
حيث تقع قاعده عسكريه روسيا الرئيسيه هناك
انسحاب روسيا المفاجاه من قرسون افسح
المجال للحديث عن اتفاق مبطن بين موسكو
واشنطن بهدف اعطاء فرصه امام المفاوضات
بما قد ايحقق السلام ويجنب العالم تصعيد
النويا الحلفاء الغربيون وان عبروا عن
التزامهم بمواصله تقدم الدعم لاوكرانيا
الا ان الاصوات التي تطالب بالدفع نحو
السلام بين المسؤولين الامريكيين
العسكريين قبل الدكتوماسيين لما تعد سريه
بل ان الصين ايضا الصوره ايضا والعهد على
قائد الاركان العامه الامريكيه والرغم
المكاسب الاوكرانيه على الارض الا انه
استبعد تحقيق الطرفين لنصر ساحق يضمن
انهاء الحرب ولهذا ببقى طالبه باللجوء الى
وسائل اخرى جبهه اخرى دبلوماسيه عبر
مستشار الامن القومي الامريكي جيكسالبان
الذي نقل رساله من اداره بايدا الى زينسكي
في الرابع من الشهر الجاري نص الرساله كان
واضحه على كيف قبول المفاوضات من اجل
الحصول على مزيد من التعاطف الدولي فكر
بواقعيه في الاولويات هكذا كشفت صحيفه
بورسجنن عن مطالبه السالفه والحديث هنا
تحديدا عن رغبه
جزيره القرم واشنطن التي دعمت وحدها كيف
بما يفصل الى 20 مليار دولار لا تتخشن
ايار مخزونها من الاسلحه في ظل حرب
الاستنزاف طويله الامد وبالتالي المفاوضات
حل مثالي استرجاعه خرسانه كان شرطا اساسيا
على نازله ان المفاوضات لن تتم بدونه لكنه
الان والان ما ما ديناميه المعارك الجديده
يرغب في تحقيق اقصى استفاده منها
رغبه ما قد تجعله يضع شروطنا للتفاوض غير
واقعيه تماما كما تحدث سالبا
[موسيقى]
ديسكو
رغم ان الغرب وتحديدا الولايات المتحده
يخشى نفهذا مخزونه من السلاح كما ذكرنا
لكن هناك ميزه لاستمرار الحرب وهي ارض
اوكرانيا هي حقل تجارب نظام الاثنين
البندقيه تقوم بتحييد المسيرات وفصلها عن
نظام الاقتصاد دخلت الخدمه قبل عامين فقط
وكثير حصلت على 50 وحده منها معتبره الامر
اولويه قسوه التجريبات عدت المعدات
الخفيفه المانيا سلمت اوكرانيا نظام
ايرستي النسخه الاحدث من النظام الدفاع
ولم تدخل الخدمه بعد في الجيش الالماني
سلاح اخر هجومي وهذه المره القوارب
المسيره الانتحاريه التي اكدت روسيا ان
اسطول البحر الاسود تعرض لهجوم بواسطتها
كيف لم تعطي تفاصيل عن الهجوم لكن مصادر
غربيه اكدت ان برلين واشنطن سلمت اسلحه
ممثله لاوكرانيا ومن الاسلحه الى انظمه
المعلومات نظاما ثوري صوره الناتو
بالتعاون مع اوكرانيا استخدم في الحرب
لاول مره دلتا طور هذا العام ليشمل 30
ميزه يلبي متطلبات الحرب والنتائج مبهره
بحسب خبراء امريكيين لصحيفه نيويورك تايمز
النظامي يقدم معلومات اوسع من كونه وسيله
انذار مبكر يجمع الخرائط الصور والصور
لمعدات العدو وعدد الجنود في الزمن
الحقيقي ويمكن ايضا دمج المعلومات التي
تصل من الاقمار الاصطناعيه وصور المسيرات
وحتى الصور التي تصل من المواطنين في
الميدان امورا جعلت فعاليته كبيره للغايه
ومكنه الاوكرانيين من كسب الوقت ومعرفه
متى واين يجب ضرب القوات الروسيه خاصه
[موسيقى]
للمزيد في هذا الملف ينضم الينا من
استوديو فارس الدكتور فادي فاضل مدير
المعهد الامريكي في باريس اهلا بك بعد
الانسحاب من خرسون سننسى الخطوات العسكريه
والميدانيه والخطط ولكن على الصعيد
السياسي هل يمكن ان تكون روسيا قد تقدمت
خطوه نحو الحل السياسي قد قدمت بادراسه
لا اظن ان الامور نضجت على صعيد الميدان
الدفاعي كي تخطو روسيا بنفسها وتاخذ
المبادره السياسيه عمليه انسحاب بها من
خير سوريا اكثر تموضع دفاع مدني عسكري من
اجل تعزيز كما سبق وقلت في التقرير وجودها
في الكروم ان هناك اولويات من ناحيه
الجيوش والعتاد ونحن قادمون على على
الشتاء وعلى الثلوج وعلى السقعه وعلى جميع
هذه العوامل الطبيعيه اذا هناك نوع من
الموضوع واظن ان الحل السياسي لن ياتي الا
في اطار تعزيز مواقع معينه تحصل عليها
روسيا من خلال هجومها على اوكرانيا
واستهلالها او احتلالها اراد او مواقع
مهمه تجعلها عندها تاتي في اطار تفاوض
سياسي لكي نجد حلا سياسيه
على اوكرانيا يعني روسيا تلعب بورقه
البنيه التحتيه الان اليوم اوكرانيا تقول
ان 50% من الكهرباء انقطعت عن البلاد 10
ملايين يعيشون بدون كهرباء الان في
اوكرانيا هل هذا يخلق موقف التفاوض افضل
او على الاقل يجبر اوكراني على التنازل
حتما هذه امور تضغط على حكومه اوكرانيا ان
تذهب في اطار المفاوضات لان نعلم ان هناك
دعم غربي
دفاعي الاوكراني من ناحيه الاسلحه من
ناحيه العتاب من ناحيه التدريب نحن نعلم
ان الموان والفراسيون
والامريكان وباخذ الدول الاوروبيه تدعم
اوكرانيا في دفاعها عن اراضيها اتجاه
روسيا وبالتالي روسيا من ناحيه
خلق ضغوطات معينه انسانيه همم تقصف هذه
المواقع السكنيه والانسانيه همم تحت حجه
ان هذه مواقع دفاعيه وهناك حضور عسكري في
هذه المناطق ولكن
كبير كبير
هو الموقف الغربي الان وتحديدا الامريكي
يعني على سبيل المثال تصريحات الجنرال
مارك مالي رئيس هيئه الاركان الامريكيه
تحدث عن احتماليه دفع رانيا روسيا
للانسحاب من اراضيها ضئيله وان روسيا لا
تزال تملك قوه وازنه في
اوكرانيا هذا من جهه وايضا لا ننسى على
سعيدا اخر تصريحات جيك سولفين طلب زينسكي
بالواقعيه وايضا اوصل رساله من الرئيس
الامريكي جوبايدا قال فيها نصا على كيف
قبول المفاوضات من اجل الحصول على المزيد
من التعاطف الدولي
روسيا هناك مسلمات لا يمكن ان تتراجع عنها
وهي كانت الحافز الاساسي في دخول الحرب
اولا عدم السماح ان تدخل اوكرانيا اي باي
حلف غربي كاملاته او كان الاتحاد الاوروبي
او كشبكه الدفاع عن اراضيها لان تعتبر
اراضي موازيه همم الحدود الروسيه ثانيا
عمليه احتلال وضم القرم غير روسيا تعتبرها
روسيا ارض روسيه تاريخيه والعيونك
الاستغناء عنها فاذا كانت الحرب على
اوكرانيا سوف تجعل من روسيا تربح هذان
العاملين اولا ال جي استراتيجي والثانيه
همم الارض القرنيه بتكريسها لروسيا حاتم
ان يكون يمكن القولون ان هذا نوع من تحصيل
مهم لروسيا اليوم ماذا تربح اوكرانيا في
تسليمها لهذا المبداين حتى الان ليس هناك
من مكاسب الاوكرانيا في بيطار لانه الاساس
في اوكرانيا بدخولها الحرب او بهجوم روسي
عليها انها كانت تريد ان تنضم الى الناتو
الناتو لم يقل لاوكرانيا هذا ما جعل روسيا
تدخل بقوه ولم تنضج همم
الحل حتى الان لان ليس هناك من امثوله
تعطيها الولايات المتحده ليش الصين من
خلال هذه الحرب وما هي التدعيات اللي يمكن
ان تتحملها الصين اذا ما اتبعت همم نوعا
نمط الروسي في احتلالها تايوان او باقي
همم
الدكتوره فادي فاضل مدير المعهد الامريكيه
في باريس من ستديو باريس
شكرا شركه فرنسا وفقراء بريطانيا بينهما
عمل المشترك في الساعه بعد دقيقه
[موسيقى]
شتاء مظلمون في بريطانيا قد يغلق فيه
اصحاب المحل التجاريه ابوابهم مجلس مدينه
بلاك بوليتوقعوا الذهاب الناس للمخدرات
اما بنوك الطعام فامدادتها تنفذ لجا اليها
320 الف شخص خلال الاشهر السته الماضيه
طلبا للمساعده واقع اقاسا تقابله خطه
للحكومه الجديده زياده الضرائب وخفض
الانفاق بقيمه 55 مليار جنيه استرليني وسط
التضخم هو الاعلى منذ اربعه عقود اجراءات
صعبه لكنها ضروريه وهكذا كانت تعليق وزير
الماليه البريطانيه جيرمن لا يهتم المواطن
البريطاني بالاحاديث وكل ما يفكر به هو
كيف سيتجاوز الشتاء قادما برودته تصل قبله
ليس المواطن البريطاني فقط وانما الاوروبي
بشكل عام فهنا فرنسا شركات كبيره تتجه لا
الافلاس والسبب لا يزال ازمه الطاقه
فواتير الكهرباء مرتفعه الطاقهحيه نسبيا
قياسا بالسناريو الاسود كارثه اقتصاديه
كبرى تلوح في الافق بالطبع حاول وزير
الاقتصاد والماليه الفرنسي في رد على
سؤالي مراسل العربيه
خفيفه من وطئتها
في ايران شعب ونظام تجمعهما الجغرافيا
وتفرقهما سنوات ضوئيه عن الواقع والمستقبل
نصف قرن اثبت فيه النظام فشله في تامين
ادنى متطلبات شعبه وحقوقهم والدليل كما
نرى انتفاضه فقراء
تحذر عدوى الوعي انتقلت اذن من الشعب الى
المسؤولين فاخيرا اعترف احدهم وان بتسجيل
صوتيا مسرب بان هذه الاحتجاجات لم يصممها
العدو بل كانت نتيجه ماسه داخليه ومشاكل
اقتصاديه اهم ما في هذا التسجيل لانه نسب
لضابه
الشرطه الشرطه
[موسيقى]
100% من قيمتها وكانها باتت الاسود عالميا
فضلا عن سقوط رموز
وهما السببان الرئيسيين الاحتجاجات
الاعتراف خلف الابواب المغلقات
لزياره امام محافظه بلوشستان التي لم تكن
لتحصل لو لم يشعر خامنئي بان سيناريو
تقسيم البلاد سيتحقق ولابد من فتره احتواء
انا ابعد عقود من تزايد البطش والتمييز
والحرمان بحق اهل البستان ومن هنا تاتي
مهمه منحه للحارس الثوري بعد تشديد قبضته
على المحتاجين الحرس ممكن بتوسيع دائره
التهديد والقمع في الخارج وزعزعه الامن في
دول الجوار عملاء الحرس تسلل الى لندن
المهمه كانت محدده تهريب الصحفيين
المعارضين وطبعا اسكاتهم حتى التهديدات
المعلنه اشعلت ازمه ديبلوماسيه ومع ذلك
قرر الطيران المجازفه لوقف نزيف سمعه
النظام واطفاء وقود الاحتجاجات الحقيقه ان
النظام يفقد سيطرته الكامله تقريبا
والانتفاضه تتحول الى ثوره والغرب يدرك ان
الحوار مع نظام الاستبدادي سيكون محرجا
ولذا قد يكون الرهان على سقوطه ورقه
الرابحه في اهم الملفات العالقه بين
الطرفين والدليل ان اوروبا اجلت حسم الملف
النووي ومعه تاجل المطلب الايراني الاول
الحرس الثوري سيبقى على قائمه الارهاب بل
وان الغرب انهال بجمله عقوبه على الدائره
الداخليه للكيان الحامل النظام
الحرس لاخماد الاضطرابات باتت محدوده
والوقت حانه لتحريك جبهات خارجيه وتشتيت
الانتباه عما يجري في الداخل الساحه
العراقيه هي اقرب هذه الجبهات وهناك جبهه
اخرى حاولت ايران فتحها وفشلت لجلت
كعادتها الى وكلاءها للتنفيذ 70 قلنا من
وقود الصواريخ البالستيه كانت في طريقها
الى الحوثيين في اليمن والهدف كان
السعوديه التي تنبات به هجوم وشيك على
اراضيه واستعدت له
الحارس الثوري لم تتوقف وهذه المره في
خليجي عمان وسياره انتحاريه ايرانيه هاجمت
ناقله نفط ويمكن التكهن بان وثيره الهجمات
سترتفع كل ما شعرت السلطات في ايران في
خطر السقوط اذا كان العمود الفقري للنظام
مهددا فما هي حال اطرافه كما يفعل المرشد
في طهران ان يردده السيد في بيروت حزب
الله يستنسخ روايه الانكار والتخوين
بحدثيرها والنقل دون اجتهاد او تفكير كما
يقال وهنا لازم تغير الخطاب نصر الله بدا
بمهاجمه المحتاجين في ايران تقيما جاء في
وصفه جاهزه للتعميم حيث يتعرض المحور
الايراني وبين لبنان وايران تشابه كبير
معي
خط الفقر ولكن تنتهي عنده هبوط العمله
الوطنيه وحلما عنوانه الهجره
تشابه يسهل مهمه امين عام حزب الله بالقاء
اللون على المؤامرات الخارجيه تماما كما
طهران واذا كانت انتفاضه المراه والشباب
الايراني هي فتنه براي سلطات طهران فمن
باب المجامله يصبح ابناء البلد في لبنان
قطعون الامريكيا براي حسن نصر الله حقو
المعلم على التلميذ لا ينتهي الا بعد موته
ونصر الله نجيبه يعملوا من اجل تحقيقه
طموحاتنا ومصلحه معلمه الاكبر ويطمع
بالحفاظ على منصبه في مشروع الحزام الذهبي
الايراني في المنطقه ما جرى في اكتوبر
2019 في لبنان يجري في نوفمبر 2022 في
ايران وهو كابوس يكشف وتملم الشعوب وتقلص
نفوذ الانظمه الاستبداديه واذرعها
ديكتاتور
[موسيقى]
كتاني اولاد
الاقليميه تحدي الابرز امام حكومه رئيس
الوزراء العراقي محمد السوداني وهنا يبدو
ان اقليم كردستان العراق
استهداف المسلحين الاكراد الانتهاك لم
يتوقف عند هذا الحد بل طال المنافذ
الحدوديه غير الرسميه التي تدشنها السلطات
الايرانيه بين اراضيها واقليم كردستان
مستمره رغم ان السوداني اذانها رغم انه
اكد قبلها اهميه الشراكه مع طهران والعمل
معها وهو مرشح الاطار الموالي لايران
الاصلي بالتالي
الى تدخل الايرانيه اكبر في شؤون العراق
رئاستيه للحكومه
استراتيجيه الرد العراقي لوقف الخروقات
الايرانيه المستمره لسياده العراق والوقوف
بوجه هجمات الحرس الثوري الايراني على
اقليم كردستان العراق مهمته لا تبدو
بالسهله على رئيس الوزراء العراقي محمد
شياع السوداني المدعوم اصلا من ايران
واذرعها السياسيه ببغداد لاسيما وان
السوداني وصل رئاسه الوزراء بدعم المباشره
من القوه الولائيه بالمقابل من الصعب ان
يتخيل العراقيون ان يعمد السوداني الى
مناكفه او اثارتها حفيظه الدول العربيه
مباشره وربما سيعان السودان من حالته من
التجاذبات والاستقطبات التي ستعصفه
بالسياسه الداخليه العراقيه وقد تلزمه
اللجوء الى سياسات تسويه ومداهنات
وبالتالي فان استراتيجيه ردعي من قبل
السوداني وحكومته في مواجهه الخروقات
الايرانيه وكذلك تركيا
احتمالاتها ضئيله بحسب مراقبين
الهجوم الايرانيه الاخيره على بلدتك وسنجق
لم يكن
الاول وعلى الارجاح لن يكون الاخير وبينما
مرت بغداد بسنواتنا من الضعف الحكوميه
وبين التنازع بين اربيل وغياب العنصر
الامني عن حدود ايران مع الاقليم المتضرر
الوحيد هو العراق كل هذه العوامل اجتمعت
اما دعم او تبرير من جبهات او جهات
الداخليه لتطيح لايران التدخل والتهديد
باستهداف في مناطق مقتضى بالمدنيين الحرس
الثوري كشف تواجده على الحدود وهذه كشف
التواجد على الحدود وهذه الاحداث تنبي
عفوا ابي امر اخر خطير ان ايران على خطط
تركيه عبر تنفيذ عمليه عسكريه داخل حدود
اقليم كردستان في حال بقيت الاحزاب
الكرديه الايرانيه المعارضه على الحدود
مجموعه من الازمات تعقد المشهد امام حكومه
السوداني اربيل اثار في ضوء اشراك الحكومه
الاتحاديه في ملفات الاقليم او نشر قواتا
اتحاديه او على حدود مع ايران ورغم
التهديد ابي اجراءاتنا من حكومه السوداني
لا شيء نفذ ولا انتهاكات اوقفت وهو ما فتح
الباب امام طهران لتوظيفهاماتها لاهدافا
سياسيه الاكراد المسلحون هم السبب في
تاجيج الاحتجاجات الايرانيه وهكذا ترى
السلطات في ايران
امرنا جعلها تواصل والهامات وتؤكد
باستمرارها والسبيل الوحيد لايقافها هو
وقف الاحتجاجات الداخليه
كيف بالضبط على الحسبين الكرديين الحاكمين
في الاقليم بهدف التاثير على اكراد ايران
ومطالبتهم بتهدئه الاحتجاجات من مصدر
شرارتها من المدن الكرديه وربما لذلك لجات
زياره جاءت الزيرتان قاني لبغداد ولقاء
السوداني ورئيس العراق لاقليم كردستان
جاره اخرى لا تلتزموا بمبادئه حزن الجوار
والذريعه دائما الاحزاب الكرديه وهي تركيا
نقاط التفتيش التركيه تنتشر في نحو الفا
وخمس 2550 كلم مربعا من اراضي شمال العراق
اين نحو ثلاثه فاصله 5% من مساحه اقليم
كردستان ومؤخرا تعدل الامر حدود الاقليم
وسعد تركيا نطاق ضربتها بطائراتها المسيره
ونفذ الضرب على عمق 281 كيلو مترا داخل
الحدود عراقيه مستهدفه المناطق خاضعه
للسلطه الاتحاديه سنجار والموصل امثله في
خطوه استفزازيه نشرت مديريه الاتصالات
التركيه خارطه عام 2020 اظهرت القواعد
العسكريه الرسميه للقوات التركيه في شمال
العراق نشر رافقه هجوم كبير
لتزيل انقره الخريطه وازاله الخريطه
الافتراديا نعم لكن الواقع لا يزال كما هو
اكثر من 10,000 جنديا تركي في العراق حسب
النسخه التركيه من صحيفه
البريطانيه ولان الجنود يحتاجون للاوامر
يزورهم من فتره لاخرى وزير الدفاع التركيه
وكمان نشاهد هي زيارات دون اختار السلطات
العراقيه بل وعدم الاكتراف باحتجاجات
بغداد المستمره رغم ان بين تركيا وايران
قاسم المشترك وهو انتهاك سياده العراق
لكنه تمت خلافات شركاء في العراق يظهرون
ظهرهم الانتهاكات ايران وينتقدون هجمات
تركيا
36 عاما كانت كفيله برفع سعرها لاكثر من
مليون دولار في الساعه بعد دقيقه
[موسيقى]
يمين انا بهذه اليد سجل هدفه الشهير ويسار
انا وبنفس اليد حملات كاس العالم وفي
المنتصف وبعد 36 عاما كره الهدف بيعه في
مزادنا في المونديال المكسيكي عام
1986 سجل النجم الارجنتيني مارادونا هدفه
الذي وصف بشائر اليس بالقدم وانما باليد
وامام منه منتخب انجلترا الذي كان ملتحما
سياسيا ايضا مع الارجنتين بسبب جزر
البوكلاند تمر عقود وتعرض الكره كره الهدف
الشهير في مازادا الزمن كان كفيله نبي
ايصال سعرها لمليونين
و400,000 دولار لكن اين المزاد
في المملكه المتحده في لندن تحديدا وغدا
نتعمق اكثر في خلق خلط السياسه بالرياضه
وقبل السعاده من انطلاق كاس العالم
الدول الاسيويه مره اخرى وجهه الامير محمد
بن سلمان جوله تبرز اهميه تلك المنطقه في
العالم ولي العهد دشنا قبل سنوات عهد
الدبلوماسيه الاقتصاديه مع دول شرق اسيا
وهذه المره من اندونيسيا وتحديدا جزيره
بالي تراسا الامير محمد بن سلمان وفتى
السعوديه المشاركه في قمه قاده دول مجموعه
ال20 في هذه الجولات تمثل الدول عمقانا
وثقل الاقتصاديا واجتماعيا مهما بدانا من
اندونيسيا اكبر بلد اسلامي من حيث التعداد
السكاني وكوريا الجنوبيه مرورا بطاليند
والسعوديه لا تفتقر للخيارات رساله ولي
العهد من الجوله هدفه بالاحرى زياده
التنسيق والشركات مع اسواق الطاقه في اسيا
احد اكبر اسواق النفط السعوديه خلال العقل
الماضي وتحديد الصين كوريا الجنوبيه
والهند
جولهنا بمناقشات واسعات تركز على التبادل
التجاري والانشاءات والتصنيع
والالكترونيات لكن من بين الاهداف ايضا
التسهيل الصادرات في المنطقه بما في ذلك
اما مشاريع التكرير ومنشات التخزين كما
يمكن للسعوديه الدخول في شراكه استراتيجيه
مع الدول الاسيويه بشان بدائل النفط الخام
جوله ولي العهد تسبق حدثين مهمين جدا
الاول الاجتماع يوم الرابع من ديسمبر
المقبل او قبل زياره مرتقبه لم يحدد
موعدها مع الرئيس الصيني للسعوديه السياسه
الخارجيه تقوموا على مبدا السعوديه اولا
اذا هي جوله تعزيز العلاقات وتطويرها في
اكبر اسواق السعوديه النفطيه اسيا كما
اسلفنا لكن الامر ليس متعلقا بالنفتفحسب
وانما بتوسيع التعاون فيما يتعلق بالسلاسل
التوريد وبدائل النفط الخام في اندونيسيا
مثلا شركه ارامكو وشركه وبرتامينا
الاندونيسيه اعلنتا عن الخطط التعاون عبر
سلسله قيمه الهيدروجين والامونيا النظيفين
تجاريين تجاوز حجم التبادل بين البلدين
العام الماضي الخمسه مليار دولار ونتحدث
هنا عن مليارين و800 مليون دولار اصادرات
سعوديه الى اندونيسيا واكثر من
250 مليون للوالده من اندونيسيا
ارامكو وسابك شركه ثاني السعوديه
عمل كبير في جاره اخرى كوريا الجنوبيه
السوق الحيويه للسعوديه في العقد الاخير
فقط تجا حجم التبادل التجاري 330 مليار
دولار كما يتشارك البلدان باكثر من 120
مشروعا الصناعيا وتجاريا واستثماريا وهناك
43 شركه كوريه تعمل على تنفيذ مشاريع كبرى
في السعوديه
تعد شركه ارامكو السعوديه من اكبر الشركات
المستثمره في السوق الكوريه فهي تستثمر في
مصفاه اس او الى ثالث اكبر مصفاه في كوريا
الجنوبيه بنسبه قدر ب
63.4% ايضا هيونداي اويل بنك مصفاه
متكامله للتكرير بطاقه معالجه تصل الى 650
الف برميل في اليوم كانت ارامكو اعلنت عام
2019 بانها استكملت صفقه استحواذ على حصه
17% من هذه الشركه تتشارك ايضا ارامكو
السعوديه مع هيونداي للصناعات ثقيله
المحدوده في الشركه العالميه للصناعات
البحريه وهي المشروع الاساسي المشترك
لمجمع الملك سلمان العالمي للصناعات
والخدمات البحريه هيونداي بالنسبه 20%
وارامكو بنسبه
40% هناك امر اخر تتشارك فيها امامك
السعوديه مع كوريا وهو استيراد سول
للهيدروجين الازرق وطبعا ارامكو تسير
بخطوات ثابته لتحقيق استراتيجيتها الهادفه
بان تصبح من اكبر مصدريه الهيدروجين
الازرق في العالم خلال السنوات المقبله
اذا كما تابعنا مع ميسون موفده العربيه في
كوريا الجنوبيه تمضي شركه ارامكو في
استراتيجيتها بالتحول الى اكبر مصدر
الهيدروجين في العالم خلال السنوات
المقبله ولنعه الى عام 2019 وقتها افتتحت
شركه ارامكو وشركه بروديكس اول محطه
للتزوج بالهيدروجين في المركز التقني
الجديد التابع للشركه في وادي الظهران على
التقنيه في السعوديه وفي 2020 انتجت
ارامكو ومع احد اقتصاديات الطاقه في
اليابان بالشراكه مع سابك اول شحنه من
الامونيا الزرقاء عاليه الجوده وقدرت
باربعين
وصدرتها الى اليابان الى الاستخدامها في
توليد الكهرباء
هي الاولى عالميا لسلسله الامداد الامونيا
الزرقاء اليوم او مع تزايد الاعتماد على
الوقود النظيف تجري شركه شلونكم محادثات
لتصدير الهيدروجين الازرق الى اسيا لا
سيما كوريا الجنوبيه واليابان خلال
السنوات الخمس المقبله وفي ديسمبر المقبل
وتوقع عن فصل اول الشحنه التجاريه من
الامونيا الزرقاء الى مدينه اولسان في
كوريا الجنوبيه والتي تقدر بخمسه وعشرين
الفطر
السعوديه اذا ناقت تراسخ نفسها في اسواق
السلسله القيمه منخفضه الكربون ارامكو
لديها هدفا واضح انتاج ما يصل الى 11
مليون طن سنويا من الامونيا الزرقاء بحلول
2030 وكما تعمل حاليا على تطوير قدراتها
في مجالها احتجاج الكربون والهيدروجين
ارامكو سابقا معادن اوبتين بورد فيرست اند
فندم سرتفيكيشن 2
30 30
من الرياضه عبر زومي ينضم الينا الدكتور
فواز العلمي وزيره الصناعه السعوديه
الاسبق والخبير في التجاره الدوليه اهلا
بك معاليك اذا مستقبل استثماري ضخم بين
السعوديه والدول الاسيويه يقوده ولي العهد
السعودي الامير محمد بن سلمان واللافت
بشكل كبير ان الاتفاقيات في جزء منها
تتعلق بمجالات المستقبل والطاقه النظيفه
لوزاره التجاره والصناعه في المملكه اااه
اذا سمحتوا لي طبعا
الجميع دول العالم عندما انضمت للنظام
العالمي الجديد من خلال تجاه العلميه
والتزم اتفاقيه المنظمات 28 اتفاقيه سعرها
هذه الدول لتكوين الشركات الاستراتيجيه مع
الدول الاخرى حتى تستطيع همم ابتسام
التقنيه منها سواء كانت في الدول المتقدمه
او الحصول على المزايا التنافسيه النسبيه
في الدول الاقل نمو الدول الناميه
وبالتالي كان اهم هدف من اهداف رؤيه
المملكه هو انشاء مركز انشاء المكتب
الرئيسي
للشركات الاستراتيجيه في المملكه والذي
يسعى لا اخذت شركات استراتيجيه مع دول
العالم همم طبعا لا شك ان الدول همم مثل
الدول شرق اسيا وجنوب شرق اسيا متقدمه جدا
في حديث العديد من
الانظمه العالميه والتقنيه العالميه في
جنوب كوريا لاحظنا انها تعتبر من الدول
الاولى في تقنيه المعلومات وايضا قامت
المملكه بتوقيت اتفاقيات التي نحن على
العلم بها 26 اتفاقيه اهمها مشروع
الهيدروجين الذي سيقام في همم منطقه نيوم
همم بحوالي 7 مليار دولار همم لان هذا هو
الاتجاه العالمي حاليا وهو تخفيف مؤقت
التغير المناخي
وايضا الدعاثات الكربون طبعا الاتفاقيه
الثانيه المهمه جدا هو الاتفاقيه التي
تعمل في جنوب سوريا همم
في انشاء العديد من الصناعات
البتروكيماويه همم وهذه ايضا وهذا ايضا
اكبر باستثمار مشروع استثماري موجود في
كوريا حاليا
دكتور دكتور ايضا هناك تركيز من من
السعوديه وفي هذه الاتفاقيات على توطين
الصناعات ان تكون السعوديه مركزا لصناعه
مختلفه في الشرق الاوسط وشمال افريقيا
ستكون بتوطين هذه السنه
والاكتساب بالتقنيه وتعطيل التقنيه وايضا
الدول الاخرى ستستطيع الحصول على المواد
الاوليه من المملكه مثل النفط
والبتروكيماويات وغيره همم
اكبر الدول العالميه في صناعه السيارات هي
تنتج حوالي مليونين سياره في العالم
وثلاثه مليون مركبه بخاريه في العام
وبالتالي فلا بد ان يكون هنالك تكامل
وترابطات
هذه الاتفاقيات وهذه الجولالي ولي العهد
السعودي ان رؤيه المملكه
2030 هي رؤيه واسعه جدا وايضا تشمل دول
اسيا اشكرك جزيل الشكر معنا الدكتور فواز
العلمي وكيل وزاره الصناعه السعوديه
الاسبق والخبير في التجاره الدوليه
[موسيقى]
تحدثنا قبل قليل عن تعاون السعودي مع عده
دول اسيويه في هدف مكافحه يتغير المناخ
ونحن هنا في جنوب شرق اسيا تايلاند تحديدا
في عاصمتها بانكوك
عليها التغير المناخي الفيضانات دمرتها
قبل عقد من الزمان وقد تدميرها في
المستقبل ايضا يمكن ان تغمر المياه 40
الاصل الاسمنت اللي تريح
لكن المفارقه تكمن في ان الطبيعه ايضا
يمكن ان تنقذها ولانها مدينه مكتظه
بالسكان فمهندسها كان لديهم الابتكار او
بوادر الحلول
سنتربايك وسط بانكوك تحارب الفيضانات
لناخذ جوله ونتعرف على الكيفيه الحديقه
مبنيه على منحدر تخزن كميات كبيره من مياه
الامطار والهدف منع الشوارع المحيطات من
الفيضانات
وجه هذه المياه عبر حدائق فرعيه وعبر
اراضي رطبه صناعيه ومنه هناك تتدفق الماء
الى بركه للتخزين ساعتها
تحت التربه
خزان مياه اضافيه يمكنه الصعاب ما يقرب من
200,000 جالون
الحديقه بالكامل اي يمكنها ان تخزن ما يصل
الى مليون جالون من المياه نحن نتحدث عن
مؤتمرات تعقد وعلى مستوى كبير لمكافحه
تغير المناخ الذي يهدد العالم
يمكنهم اخذ المثال من بينكوك المناطق
الخضراء
المقاومه للمناخ ولتغير المناخ استثمار
جيد طويل الامد للمدن وافضل الحلول للجيل
القادم
وصلنا الى نهايه الساعه ستكون وتتابعونا
غدا من النصفيات الى تجهيز الرئاسيه
انتخابات امريكا من هو الاقل شرا
المونديال يبدا بعد ايام قليله كره القدم
ساحره السياسيه
[موسيقى]
في نهايه الساعه ابرز واحداث الساعه بصور
من الان وحتى الساعه المقبله انا حنين
الشولي وهذه الساعه 6:00
[موسيقى]